ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah to call out to people in your field of vision
there are suspicious people in the world
i found one person i
'm sure that
's the bancho i hate school because there's that kind of person i'm
going back to back ah ah
teacher  It's still a match, but you should team up over there
Eh,
I
can do it
alone, so you can't do it alone,
right?
[Music] It
seems like social life is a shitty thing My
dream for the future is to have 1,000 people I want friends, but if you want friends there,
why don't you turn your uppers into money
?  Ha
, I'm not a raccoon, so I'm not a raccoon, so
I've followed
you I wonder if it's
this one I collected
Doumou
yeah
, my mother said I shouldn't take money from people, so I'm going to sell it on the train, so excuse me
You don't have to follow me. I've
never ridden a bridge train.
Ha 8
Anu Why have I never ridden?
In
general, I'm not
a friend, so I'm not a friend, so I'm going
to use Type and Geed together.
Are your friends monsters?